[Music]
10 minutes here we go 10 plus Z yeah we
might we might have to restart the
speedrun pretty soon but I'm down for
like one or two more games on this
account here we go 2281 stockfish gaming
69 joined three days ago um okay looks
like looks like he's legit though
because he's played a lot of standard
games okay yeah he's played a lot of
standard
games let's keep going all right so
we're going to get a knight or
fin Knight F6 Knight finally we get a
Mainline Knight or it's been a while we
we constantly face anti-sicilians but at
this level the open Sicilian becomes
very very
popular F3 okay so we have faced this
line exactly once in the speedrun uh
this was that was a very technical
speedrun video where I really delved
deeply into the theory of What's called
the English attack and in the English
attack white plays this early F3 move
generally develops the bishop to E3 then
plays Queen D2 long castle and then
essentially sends his pawns down the
king side and and and you get the kind
of stereotypical nter of battle where
black attacks on the queen side and
white attacks on the king side but
Bishop B2 is a more modest approach it's
not a particularly dangerous move I mean
it's not all that great for white to
combine uh to combine the move F3 and
short Castle because it is it is a
relatively weakening move but it's
obviously not the end of the world so
black is not like much better or
anything we should just continue playing
normally and I'm going to continue
developing my pieces as is kind of
customary in the nidorf where typically
the Knight heads to D7 rare is the
instance where you develop the Knight to
C6 and there's positional reasons for
that that I'll get into after the game
but black is already a good position out
of the opening typically uh essentially
white is combining two different
variations one is the quiet the carpa
variation Bishop B2 and the other is the
English attack and sometimes when you
mix two lines uh you get kind of a
mishmash and you give your opponent
comfortable play Queen D2 okay so let's
continue making marginal improving moves
I like the look of Rook C8 I like the
look of the typical knight orph move B5
of course when you play B5 you have to
be very careful uh not to allow A4 which
can lead to very unpleasant dissolution
of your king uh Queen side so let's
start with a more non committ improving
move Rook C8 and Knight D5 okay so here
we have a choice we can take with a
knight and after e takes D5 we can park
our Bishop on F5 this is typically how
I've been taught to respond to this move
we can also of course take with the
bishop and after e takes D5 we can start
playing positionally on the king side I
think both options uh contain a good
deal of sense but I think the standard
approach is Knight takes D5 e and Bishop
F5 maintaining the bishop pair
and now the plan well first of all the C
Pawn is hanging so presumably our
opponent is going to go C4 and then the
plan that I was taught when I was first
learning the KN or is to drop this
bishop back to G6 and to quickly send
our kingside pawns up the board so we
almost get in effect a reverse English
attack where white is going to play on
the queen side and we are going to play
on the king's side which I have no
problems with as a king's Indian player
I prefer to play against my opponent's
king okay so Bishop G6 now I'm anti
ipating C4 but the catch is that we
don't just have to close our eyes and
you know pray that nothing's going to
happen on the on the queen side we can
actively try to hurt White's chances on
the queen side so A4 is a really high
level move because C4 could have been
met with B6 slowing down the progress of
White's pawns A4 is a very good
prophylactic move right now B6 doesn't
work because it blunders the A6 pawn and
after white plays C4 if we go B6 then
then white can undermine our Our Queen
side blockade with A5 so we have no
nothing better to do than to initiate
our own kingside attack let's go F5 and
we're just going to send our our Center
pawns down the board very likely we're
going to play F4 followed by E4 or even
in some instances E4 followed by F4 now
G3 is really asking for it it's really
asking F4 it now E4 here is very
ineffective because it weakens the D4
Square it gives the Knight a potential
outpost on E6 I do like F4 a lot more
and it usually isn't even a question you
kind of have to play F4 in this
situation even without calculating this
just looks like the right move opening
up our opponent's king and leading to
direct tactical confrontation so we're
going to have to do some heavy
calculation here especially because I'm
lower on time so okay EF Bishop F4 I
have to calculate in silence for a bit
here cuz we don't actually have to play
takes F4 we can keep the pawn on E5 and
make a an improving move
such as Bishop H5 yeah have a cool idea
all right let's take let's take um ah
our opponent also can play Bishop F2 but
he takes on F4 and now I'm really hoping
that this works out let's centralize our
Knight I'm really hoping for Knight D4 I
think that's the move that most people
would play here is Knight D4 heading for
E6 but I believe that Knight D4 is a
blunder for a very instructive tactical
reason so I'm really really hoping that
we get Knight D4 here now if our
opponent takes on E5 then we take back
with the pawn and I'm getting what I
want which is control of the dark
squares on the king side as well as uh
the pawn on E5 restricting the Knight on
B3 preventing it from moving to D4 which
is would be very beneficial to us the
move that I would play with white very
high level move is something like King
H1 okay so this
guy's strong title player strength okay
so King H1 Knight C4 is possible takes
takes Knight D4
takes looks very promising but it's hard
to actually find a followup here and
feels like I'm getting outplayed in
every Speed game The Last like 30 games
okay what about Queen D7 Queen H3 this
is an interesting idea too yeah let's go
Queen
D7 and try to implement and and and more
directly involve the queen in the attack
via H3 yeah very sharp position I mean I
in in Blitz I really like black here
because we have EAS ways to continue
attacking on the other hand we're down a
pawn and obviously there's this very big
weakness on E6 so we really really I
mean if we allow the Knight to get to E6
especially if it shuts off our queen
that would be really bad news which is
why I'm playing Queen D7 I'm trying to
slide the queen into the attack kind of
before the the gates close so if our
Queen is already on H3 wow C3 that looks
wrong that looks wrong but I can't put
my finger on why there's not a move that
I would play Queen
H3 I guess is logical to start with
involving the
queen yeah if we're given a move uh we
could lift The Rook up to H5 but I'm
assuming he's going to go Knight
D4 okay he takes on E5
interesting well generally this is what
we want but obviously the situation has
changed a little bit now D6 is possible
okay so Rook F3 doesn't work D6 doesn't
work unfortunately we don't have Bishop
G5 here which we used to that's a bit of
a problem Bishop H4 comes to mind yeah
Bishop H4 very much comes to mind Rook
d8 also possible wait Rook fd8 Queen D5
check Bishop
F7 yeah Rook fd8 might be the clinical
approach here Rook cd8 there is CD
that's bad but Rook
fd8 might be a nice way to pick off this
Pawn I really don't know Bishop H4 also
possible but I really don't want to let
this Pawn live any longer than we have
to okay let's go Rook
fd8 trying to pick up thank you GM chica
to Cowboy Dixon trying to pick up the D6
Pawn we're also trying to pick up in a
way such that our attack on H2 increases
if we take it with the bishop then we'll
have the later possibility of pushing E4
and opening up a direct attack on H2 so
if white doesn't come up with anything
super concrete right now and we're able
to win back this Pawn then we're doing
amazingly the the pawn count could not
be more irrelevant here that's not the
point okay Rook D1 is a good is a great
sign now we could take with the Rook I
think a lot of people would be tempted
by this move but as I've already
explained the thematically correct move
is Bishop takes D6 because it sets up
the idea of E4 on the other hand this
move does not come with Tempo but my
intuition tells me to play Bishop takes
D6 now E4 is a very very powerful idea I
wouldn't necessarily call it a threat
but it's it's a very strong idea note
that Queen D5 check is never dangerous
because we can always block with our
other Bishop Bishop F7 and the Knight on
B3 is also left hanging in many of these
variations thank you for the sub distant
187 very high tension position but I
really feel like our attacking chances
should outweigh White's pressure in the
center okay there was a lot to unpack
there in the last couple of moves I know
that I was a little wishy-washy about
some of the Vari
because didn't have to them out I'll
cple of them theen G5 okay G5
interesting move Bishop C2 no that
doesn't look right what about E4 E4 F4
E3 man that looks very promising and E4
has to be the right move E4 Rook D6 Rook
D6 on the other hand E4 F4 threatens
Bishop G4 for F4
E34 go somehow he holds on there Queen
G5 is an excellent move I might also
just want to drop back to E6 here yeah
let's go Queen E6 I think this is the
more practical approach um E4 I didn't
like the look of
f4 this move I like because it also hits
what oh my gosh that's insane okay
Knight C5 it's not the end of the world
now I can't take with either piece of
course I didn't see that he's Way Beyond
my pay grade
I'll go Queen F7 I think we're holding
on
here yeah we're holding on
here okay Bishop C7 I didn't want to
play Bishop E7 because that would have
dropped the E5 pawn and I really don't
want to give away this
Pawn KES takes now I think uh black is
doing quite fine we're low on time and
I'm GNA have to be super precise Rook D1
okay so takes takes takes takes and I
don't quite get what I want
in the interest of time I think trading
in something like Queen C4 is the most
practical approach trading in H6 is also
possible yeah definitely I think we
should trade okay a very difficult
decision now by our opponent requiring
some thought so now let's go H6 and
chase away the queen also I want to
create a Lo Square for a king on H7 and
definitely feels like black is slightly
better here because he's got these weak
pawns he's got the long-term weakness of
his King which could cost him even
without the Rooks on the board
Queen E3 I think we're going to King H
tucking away the King on what I think is
probably the safest sare on the board
because the Knight is completely
restricted he's never going to have
Knight G5 Knight
F2 okay now Queen C4 Fields right
activating the queen activating the
queen I would really love to put my
Bishop on B6 if that Bishop starts
firing on this diagonal that would be
amazing now that becomes possible the
issue though is Bishop C2 I really
didn't want to allow the trade of of
Bishops and I missed that was a mistake
by me probably even trading might be the
most prudent option some oh I can
actually go Queen F4 wait a second Queen
F4 Bishop C2 I have Queen uh Queen C1
okay so I found a way to keep the the
bishop air alive and we're continuing to
put pressure Knight H3 what is going on
here Queen C1 has to be the move
optimizing the activity of the queen and
our next move is to be Bishop B6 to get
this bishop active I'm assuming he's
going to go King G2 and unpin his King I
mean that's what most people would do
that's what I would do Knight F2 jeez B2
okay Bishop B6 I have no real other way
to improve my position and Knight D3
Queen G5 is very important because
there's a m threat on G1 so a lot of
threats being created here and a lot of
tactics are kind of brewing in this
position the issue is if he plays a move
like Knight E4 the question comes okay
how do I actually convert my Superior
peace activity into of course he plays
it into a winning Advantage so I'm just
going to keep poking and prodding and
try to milk his clock down um and keep
creating threats following Smith lov's
advice if you create 40 threats
eventually your opponent's going to
buckle although this guy doesn't seem to
have any plans buckling let's go king h8
unpinning the king or unpinning the
bishop now I'm setting up Bishop H5
which would put pressure on this Pawn
que D1 I think Bishop H5 is sensible to
attack F3 unfortunately he's got King G2
he's defending extremely well but the
clock situation is now even what am I
going to do if he plays King G2 though I
don't quite know King G2 is basically
automatic I think maybe Queen E3 setting
up threats on this long diagonal the
very important detail the bishop is
guarding d8 if it wasn't Queen d8 would
be immediate Checkmate because King H7
there's Knight G m double attack on the
king I I really like the look of a move
like Queen E3 just kind of squeezing my
way into some of these weak squares he's
taking a really long time here it's a
good sign I think this game might be
decided on the clock our opponent's time
usage feels very unnatural to me I'm
going to be honest here King G2 is a
completely automatic move for anybody
over like 1,600 there are no other ways
to defend F3 so could be an internet
problem but I don't know what's going on
Knight D2 okay okay that is
suicidal that is I mean even Queen takes
D2 is possible but Queen D2 Queen D2
Bishop F3 there's Queen
G2 but that is a un Unthinkable move
just because of Bishop
E3 I I don't understand that moment at
all this is going to lose but white is
losing just Bishop D2 that's it we're up
a piece yeah bit of a strange resolution
and he resigns bit of a strange
resolution but an interesting game
overall yeah I me this is the reason I
kind of want to start a new speed and a
lot of these recent games to be honest I
mean as you can see are are weird the
time usage was weird some of the moves
were weird the fact that he played
Knight C5
instantly but spent you know a minute on
a move that anybody over 1400 would
never play yes a little bit strange uh
but King G2 is is is just automatic and
the position is equal after Queen E3
according to the
engine so anyways let's take a look
let's take a
look so I'm gonna uh because this game
is very complex I'm going to load it
into chess base and turn on stockfish
there because it's worthy of closer
analysis the accuracy was 85.3 to 89.6
so I played quite decently and we had a
narf so F3 E5 Knight B3 Bishop B6 Bishop
B3 Bishop B7 is all theoretical Bishop
B2 is is a a side move again it's it's
not a mistake but it's just not
considered the most ambitious line I'll
direct you to the previous speedrun game
where we did face Queen D2 castles
castles and here the move that I really
really like to play this is a sideline
and I play this very successfully even
against GMS and Blitz it's this weird
looking move A5 just trying to send the
A- Pawn up the board the main line here
uh is or sorry it's not B5 it's Knight
bd7 and now you have this crazy line
that goes G4 B5 G5 B4
pandemonium lot of theory and I went
into this in the previous uh night or
speedrun game so I'm not going to do it
again but suffice it to say that A5 is
my sort of official recommendation here
because a lot of people don't know what
to do against this move at all levels um
black is worse after A5 if white
demonstrates you know big Precision but
it's a very very dangerous sideline um
most people play Bishop B5 here to stop
A4 and already after Knight A6 I think
black's position is quite good the best
move is A4 but not a lot of people kind
of have the guts to push upon where
their King is and it also weakens the B4
Square um so Bishop B2 uh was has been
played a million times of course again
can't call this move a mistake it takes
the game kind of out of theory okay so
castles castles King side and by
transposition we get a position that
could have occurred via the move order
Bishop E2 so if White had started with
Bishop B2 after E5 Knight B3 uh
typically black starts with Bishop B7 in
this line and there's kind of a nuanced
reason for that but here the line one of
the main lines does go Bishop E3 Bishop
B6 castles castles but in this position
F3 is not a very ambitious move and it's
easier to see that when you have this
position I mean here F4 is a line Queen
D2 is a line but F3 is kind of a weird
move because it's not very necessary to
protect the E4 Pawn in this line Black's
not really putting pressure on that pawn
so we kind of get what we want here of
course again the position is still equal
so Knight bd7 Queen D2 the main move
according to uh reference on on chess
base is in fact B5 uh I rejected B5
because of
A4 um B4 Knight D5 But Here There is a
very important subtlety so after Bishop
takes D5 e takes D5 uh if you give white
like one more move to to play the move
to A5 then the Knight on D s is
completely restricted and these pawns
become isolated but because black has
the tempo you have a very important move
here can anybody name it and I've given
you a very big hint of course so it's
not A5 it's not A5 why not A5 the
problem with the move A5 is that white
can play C3 and you're like well why is
C3 so dangerous well after you trade
white is going to once again play C4
creating a very secure Pawn chain and or
orating long-term pressure on the A5
Pawn which is going to be very
unpleasant also black is very cramped
and the issue is that if you play Knight
B6 now you are just not in time white
plays C4 and already this Pawn is
hanging so it's very important to play
this move Knight to B6 here you this is
a a classic idea in the Knight ORF I I
should have seen this now white is not
in time to play C4 because of on pant
and you take D5 you might say well
what's the problem why can just play
Bishop B6 but giving away the dark
squirt Bishop uh in these types of
structures is generally very bad for
white because White's got a lot of dark
Square weaknesses partially due to the
move F3 so after King H1 you could bring
the Rook into C8 um now again white
cannot play C4 this time because the
Knight is going to hang so what is white
going to do probably A5 there are still
games in the database you will not
believe this you will not believe what I
am seeing right now this position
occurred in the game John jefra versus
Alan nitzki that's my brother in
2009 with this exact move
order I can't believe this oh my gosh
and the game ended in a draw pretty
quickly that's crazy uh San Francisco
2009 now my brother was
2052 when this game was played yeah so
we we have a lot in common except he
after Rook fd1 he played the move Knight
D7 which is actually not a bad move but
according to the engine you should start
expanding on the king side with G6 and
and King G7 H5 you know play like a
Soviet school boy on the king side and
uh if Rook A4 then you can always
protect the pawn with Rook AB8 I'm I'm
going to text him this this is insane I
mean what are the odds of that um of
course we both play the narf at that
point
but that's that's
remarkable uh currently 2100 but he
doesn't play anymore see if I can find
yeah I I also had a similar game but I'm
not going to bother finding it right now
in any case pretty crazy uh last thing
after Knight B6 if white plays Queen
takes B4 then of course you play Knight
B takes D5 and this is a very favorable
trade for black because the queen has to
drop back you take the bishop and now
you have a very nice maneuver Knight D5
and the Knight sinks its teeth into F4
Queen B6 is coming black is better so I
think the best move probably would have
been B5 and then you can continue if
white doesn't play A4 if white plays A3
for instance uh you can play Rook C8 or
you can play Knight B6 and Knight C4
black has kind of a dream knarf so
instead Rook C8 Knight
D5 so now once again I played the wrong
here I made a mistake Knight takes D5
gives away the advantage and uh this is
just sort of my standard reaction to
Knight D5 but once again after Bishop D5
Ed I completely forgot about the
prospect of Knight B6 I just kind of
assumed that White's going to go C4 and
uh if black plays B5 in this position uh
you're giving away the A5 Square also
you're allowing A4 and in this version
this is a this is an inferior version
for black in 2009 I was already stronger
than than my brother so Knight takes D5
a little bit sloppy now the position is
probably dynamically balanced okay so
Rook fc1 there's still a game in the
database here but Rook fc1 is a weird
move I feel like most people would play
C4 and here my idea was to play B6 and
if white plays A4 a very instructive
situation occurs after A5 notice that
white is completely stuck along the dark
squares you essentially can never push
C5 the reason is because you can't push
B4 because black is controlling both of
the key dark squares this also happens
sometimes in the Kings Indian it can be
compared to a situation that often
happens in the king's Indian where
um let's just take a sample line for
instance D5 Knight C5 I had this earlier
today in a Blitz game so here if white
plays A3 you get kind of a uh similar
situation the worst thing to do for
white would be to play A4 like the old
chess engines used to recommend moves
like A4 but the queen side is now
completely Frozen because B4 is never
going to be effective and Black's hands
are essentially untied for kingside
Action so from that perspective I think
Rook fc1 is a really good move uh
because it maintains Queen side
flexibility um only one game in the
database here okay so Bishop G6 I think
is a good move preparing F5 white plays
A4 now once again if White had played C4
we would have stopped the further
progression of the pawn with
B6 yeah of course white can surpass the
blockade but it takes a million moves
and those million moves give us the
opportunity to develop kingside play so
the benefit of A4 as I explained is
white essentially wants to push A5
preventing the B Pawn from moving
forward and only then does white want to
send the C Pawn in motion so we have to
get down to business which we did F5 and
G3 is a very strange move and this has
to be a mistake because this allows us
to ignite to ignite the king side again
I G3 is a very unnatural move to me I
think C4 was called for and uh the
computer gives a very interesting move
here for black Bishop H4 which I
actually really like because you're
setting up the threat of f4 and you
might say well why is F4 a threat let's
say white plays A5 you play F4 I guess
Bishop A7 is possible but that's very
scary and if white plays Bishop F2 then
you take on F2 and you play the move E4
and in these types of situations E4 is
extremely strong not only because it
opens up the king side but also because
it gives the knight uh this incredible
Square on E5 and here the attack becomes
extremely strong everything is coming
out to its prop ER positions so just
remember this idea of starting with
Bishop H4 and and only then playing up4
probably white should play a move like
King H1 here to to open up the G1 Square
for the bishop but still F4 Bishop G1
and once again E4 F takes C4 and here
you can play Knight E5 you can even play
Knight F6 and Knight takes E4 from a
practical standpoint Black's position is
amazing the attack is very very strong
and that should kind of make sense to
you someone was asking what happens if
white plays F4 and tries to physically
prevent yeah F4 is not a bad move but
what Square does F4 weaken well it
weakens the E4 Square so I would play
Knight F6 here aiming the Knight to E4
and this is merely a temporary stop Gap
Black's pieces are extremely active so
for example A5 Knight E4 and remember
that you're not you haven't sacrificed
anything so it's not like you have to
play only on the king side you can also
make a neutral move like Bishop F6 and
just kind of accumulate the pieces
nicely in the center and White's just
too slow by the time white actually
sends the C Pawn in motion already the
situation the position is already
collapsing so you know keep that in
mind yeah so G3 F4 kind of is called for
exploding the king side but somewhere
here I made a mistake so takes takes
takes knight5 is actually the top engine
move and I think the critical position
occurs after King
H1 I think the critical position occurs
after King H1 now to some people it
might be tempting to play Rook F4 and
Bishop G5 this is a nice looking tactic
but remember it's just a trade you're
actually allowing white to take on D6
and you're not actually gaining anything
from this operation so you're not
writing a tactics book as my coach would
say you're trying to win the game now
one very important detail if White had
played Knight D4 here who can tell me
the entire winning variation for black
not just the next move but what's like
the final move of the
sequence this is on the theme of just
because a move is ineffective in one
position doesn't mean you need to stop
considering it in all positions good
time to pause the video if you're
watching on YouTube yeah so the move is
Rook takes F4 now one important detail
if white starts with Knight E6 Intero
you have Queen B6 check and this is the
direct result of white playing that move
F3 right this is why weakening squares
diagonals in the long run can cost you
because the tactics don't go your way if
Queen takes F4 Bishop G5 white no longer
has moves along this diagonal the queen
has to drop back and now the key move is
Bishop E3 check you pick up the Knight
and you're completely winning you have
two pieces for a rook and just total
minor piece domination this was an
important detail but our opponent saw
through it and he played King H1 I think
that's a good move and here apparently I
made a no actually Queen D7 is a decent
move according to the computer the best
move would have been Knight to
C4 this is a difficult move to play
because you are giving away your very
strong Knight what is the idea of this
move well white has to take otherwise
white drops the bishop and if white
plays Queen to D4 then Bishop F6 is
crushing now what is the consequence of
this trade well first of all the Rook
laterally gets into the action hitting
the Bishop from both sides second of all
and mainly the F3 Pawn is now a much
more attackable Target so white has to
play Knight D4 intercepting the attack
on the bishop because if the bishop had
moved instead then you would have taken
on F3 and here the flood gates really
open Bishop B4 is coming Bishop G5 Etc
and here very important move uh Bishop
H4 this I missed I I saw Knight C4 and I
kind of stopped here and I figured oh
you know the knight's coming to E6 this
is really unpleasant but Bishop H4 is a
key detail very very high level now you
might say well how does this stop Knight
E6 now you play Queen F6 the queen is
able to slide into the attack and if
white plays Knight takes f8 then you
simply recapture on f8 and you're
winning because now the bishop is
hanging and if the bishop moves back
then all hell breaks loose Queen takes
F3 check white has to block with the
queen and now a sexy retreating move
Queen to H5 and just look at the light
Square weaknesses the bishop is coming
to E4 and white is unable to cover all
the bases if white plays Rook
then The Rook comes C2 beautiful Harmony
of of Black's pieces here everything on
the perfect square when you analyze of
the engine you always find this to be
the case like somehow the pieces are
always on the perfect squares now you
might say well what if white doesn't
take the Rook well white is no choice
because our next move is Rook takes F4
we're going to take the bishop and we
have enough attackers liquidating into a
completely winning end game two Bishops
for a rook and everything's
collapsing so all of this hinges on this
bishop H4 move which I missed kind of
getting the bishop out of the way to
pave the way for the queen to join the
attack an instructive idea to put into
your toolkit now more commonly you see
the bishop kind of dropping back to f8
uh but here it's impossible because f8
is blocked so you actually make a move
along the same diagonal now where do you
see this sometimes what would I compare
this to I would compare this to the
following let me see if I can find an
example okay yeah so very primitive
example just quickly but still it'll
it'll illustrate the point okay
so Czech Republic Championship 1907
classic um so here after King F1 F takes
G5 it's the same type of technique where
when the bishop is in front of the queen
you want it to be the other way around
so you engineer that Bishop takes H7 and
on the next move the queen slides into
G6 kind of the same type of idea here
it's much more evident that this is good
because you're just winning everything
essentially anyways that's kind of the
technique to to keep in mind let's go
back to the game so I missed this and
instead I played Queen D7 I had the
right idea to get the queen involved but
not the best execution now C3 is a very
strange move our opponent does not
respond to any of the threats Knight D4
was called for and after C3 I'm very mad
at myself because I played a very
impulsive and very bad move this is a
good example of tunnel vision I had
already set my sights on H3 and I didn't
ask myself where else can the queen go
along this diagonal what would have been
a much more effective way to force white
to do what we want to do are there any
alternatives and okay now that I ask you
the move should be obvious yeah so again
it's this I didn't pay enough attention
to the F3 pawn queen F5 so Bishop takes
E5 is forced and now Bishop to G5
Intero lovely attacking Motif if the
queen drops back then we can simply take
the Rook
and White's losing a ton of material
Bishop takes D6 Bishop takes B2 hitting
the other Rook very nice and then Bishop
takes C3 hitting the queen if white
plays F4 trying to intercept and hit the
bishop that gives away the E4 Square
Queen E4 check King G1 and Rook takes F4
beautiful again the Bishops are just
killer in this situation the diagonal
attackers for example Queen D3 check
here and Checkmate yeah that's that's
how you're supposed to attack ridiculous
um so Queen F5 was missed or I saw this
out of the corner of my I didn't see
Bishop G5 I didn't see the intermo
because if if black plays D takes E5
here that gives white a necessary Tempo
that he can use to bring Defenders uh to
the right squares and now Bishop G5 is
no longer possible the attack is less
convincing okay one second sorry I had
to refresh
because okay so instead Queen H3 and
already after Bishop takes E5 and D6 the
situation is a lot more complex uh here
Rook fd8 was a very important
detail not kind of in your mind
separating the board but understanding
that everything is related Rook FD was a
tough move to play because I was really
in love with the idea of sacking on F3
but I realized that it wasn't feasible
because anytime you play Rook takes F3
first of all there's this check on D5
that's very very nasty and second of all
the bishop can take and then the queen
can block instead Rook fd8 why not Rook
C because of D takes
E7 and white gets way too much material
for the queen two Rooks in a piece so
here it was very important to note the
tactics and after Rook FD once again
black is has a stable Advantage here
here Queen G5 was a very nice move
though by our opponent and here E4 uh
runs into F4 threatening Bishop G4 and I
just thought this was a super super
messy position E3 Rook D4 and apparently
it's equal so was very good in foresight
by our opponent to to play this move
Queen G5 kind of covering a bunch of
important squares on the king side yeah
so I kind of mentioned Bishop C2 and I
rejected this intuitively it just looks
way too flimsy and at the very least
white has the move Rook G1 and also at
the very most hitting G7 and now the
Knight can drop back to D2 and maneuver
to E4 and the bishop is very misplaced
so so as I explained Rook takes D6 would
have been possible and according to the
computer Rook takes D6 would have been
preferable followed by Rook to F6 reinv
volving The Rook but I was really
enthralled with the idea of pushing E4 I
just missed Queen G5 this is just a nice
defensive move this is very concrete I
wouldn't call this instructive these
moments in the game are just completely
predicated on concrete variations
there's no necessarily logic behind them
like why does this fail just because of
the specifics of the position because
White's pieces are at the right spots at
the right time and this is what you have
to understand about Chess at this level
a lot of it is going to come down to
these these concrete details including
Knight C5 which is an incredible move
which I of course completely missed
using the pin against the bishop and
once the Knight gets to E4 I think white
has completely stabilized probably black
is maybe a smidge better but not much
and the engine actually gives equality
so after Bishop C7 we traded Rooks the
game is starting to head toward a draw
once again very good Insight by our
opponent noticing that this is not
Checkmate the queen can block and white
is completely safe so once again very
accurate H6 Queen E3 King H7 so here I
was trying to put some Pressure Queen C4
activating the queen yeah as far as I
understand our opponent was defending
very accurately I would play Knight E4
here I would never go Knight H3 I would
keep this Knight on e4 to keep this
bishop at Bay but somehow he went to H3
allowing Our Queen to infiltrate
Knight back to F2 this should be 694 so
still very reasonable defense and really
up until Bishop C2 king h8 of course if
you play Bishop H5 immediately you run
into the double check so up until this
moment after King G2 the position is
equal so just a completely mindboggling
blunder at the end of the game after
such a nice defense here the engine
gives B4 A5 takes takes Knight back to
G3 I mean it's just an equal end game
it's it's just it's just an equal
position this is likely to liquidate
into a draw so yeah Knight D2 was just
Unthinkable obviously this allows Bishop
B3 and the game ends immediately because
F3 hangs likely with Pillsbury mate so
yeah a little bit of an anticlimactic
finale but the interesting part of the
game was like the Early Middle game when
I got that attack I started off very
accurately with Knight E5 very patient
move but then missing Bishop H4 and then
missing queen to F5 and Bishop G5 which
tells you how hard it is to attack
accurately and you shouldn't feel bad if
your attacks fail attacking is probably
the hardest stage of the game um but
yeah super fun stuff another knar win
yeah this line definitely was not
dangerous from a theoretical standpoint
but hopefully if you're a knar flairer
you're also now well well acquainted at
how to play these types of structures
remember this Knight B6 idea um I
definitely needed a refresher on this
idea so the the key here is to determine
whether white can play C4 if white can
play C4 this is not effective but here
white can't play C4 and on that I think
we are going to wrap up for today I hope
you enjoyed the game this will be on
YouTube pretty soon thanks everybody for
[Music]
watching